now let's talk skin care thanks to SMG
Media Group the sponsors of this segment
I'm introducing you to Lana Kerr founder
and CEO of Loomis Lou Loomis skin care
ladies she has created a product for
your faith and for your just you just
gotta watch it to find out Lana welcome
to Las Vegas now hi it's good to be here
nice to meet you Rocky it's so nice to
meet you you are lovely please tell us
how we can have our skin looking like
yours well I tell you it's a it's a
secret to so many people still because
they were still relatively new but it's
CO2 lift carboxy gel and it's uh
basically what carboxy therapy is is a
therapeutic use of CO2 gas to regenerate
the skin
when you put CO2 gas into the skin the
body naturally responds by rushing
oxygen-rich blood to that area so it's
going to get rid of waste it's going to
fill your skin with hydration so it's
going to look glowy and dewy but I think
more importantly it's bringing
elasticity to the skin hydration to the
skin which is going to make you look
younger for a very long time absolutely
and what do you think is that age range
where people should start using these
products do you know that they say that
elasticity starts to decrease in the
skin from before from around 20 to 25.
so if you think about that this is the
only product that is clinically proven
to increase elasticity by 26 after only
six applications so I think around that
age is a great age to start as well as
obviously you know as we get older and
we want to reverse if we didn't take
great care of our skin and I think
particularly in Vegas I mean you think
about dry dry weather this increases
hydration in the skin over 117 after one
application we call ourselves the
fastest way to better skin because it
really is this jet fuel for skin
regeneration I think what separates it
is that first of all it's a medical
grade product that someone can do in the
privacy of your home as I mentioned
elasticity that's something that you
don't really get from other products 26
without something that's going to be
invasive as well as a hydration factor
and then also once you do a series you
can easily maintain that monthly
um again doing it at home okay and this
product is for all people men women
um but you have a product specifically
for women what is that and why is it
specific for women well we have one in
the intimate Wellness area
um revolver vaginal rejuvenation I think
it makes it special to me especially as
a woman
um because we don't really have anything
that addresses that intimate area for us
and you know we don't talk about it
enough but as the skin on our face gets
older and thinner it's similar down
there and when that happens it creates
dryness it creates lack of sensitivity
it creates you know coughing and peeing
on yourself I mean things that make life
not as uh enjoyable or you know decrease
our quality of life as a woman so this
is really addressing those issues for a
woman again she can do it in the privacy
of her home how can people get more
information or keep up with your
products where can they get them here in
town well you know we have some local
derms that carry it so you can go to the
Durham Bros um they are Las Vegas
Dermatology with Dr and Dr Cotter and
then Dr spam with Couture medical so
that's locally but other than that you
can go to the website
um co2lift.com those providers have the
professional version but we have one
direct to consumer co2lift.com that they
can look at information on the product
and also get it for themselves I do
podcasts so I'd love to have these women
new triers on of the CO2 live V on on on
our podcast so we're actually launching
in a couple months
thank you to SMG Media Group for
sponsoring that segment for more
information head to uh
co2lift.com and Lana has a very special
offer for you you can use
lvnow15 as a code for 15 off the online
store we'll be right